It's my pleasure to welcome Arkid Sharma
today
for our guest lecture.
He's currently a research scientist at
Google DeepMind where he focuses on post
training and reasoning research. He's
also
creator of the direct preference
optimization DPO algorithm
which is really
foundational algorithm for aligning
large language models with human
preferences.
And most recently he led the development
of the Gemini Deep Think model,
the first AI model to achieve the gold
medal on problems from the International
Mathematical Olympiad.
And yeah, with this please give him a
very warm welcome.
And the
>> [applause]
>> stage is yours.
All right, thank you for the
introduction or and yeah,
very excited to talk to you all about
scaling test and compute.
All right.
Um and my slides are visible, right?
Yes.
Yeah, good.
>> Cool. Great. So,
um I hope like everybody is like very
familiar with LLMs these days. Um
there's
few canonical ones that I've put up
here. Um
and these are really big and integral
part of my life and hopefully like a lot
of us like
these tools have billions of users.
They're generating like insane amount of
revenue right now and they're commanding
such high valuations. Um and these
really are
um giving us a peek into what AGI would
look like.
So, a large large part of the success of
LLMs have resulted from the scaling of
the competition that is going into it
and put into the neural network machines
that are they are.
And up until 2024,
a lot of the improvements in these
systems could be attributed to scaling
the compute via pre-training.
Pre-training is this large state it goes
through where um it scrapes a lot of the
data from the internet and other
sources, and it trains ever larger
models. And all of these models are
trained to predict the next token, so
these become like really strong
prediction machines, and it's a very
scalable objective.
And perhaps like maybe to a surprise of
like a lot of the machine learning
computing, scaling this really simple
technique like allows the model to
become a lot lot better in a very
general way.
So up until 2024, a lot of the gains in
LLMs were a result of scaling the
pre-training compute.
Late in 2024 and early 2025, we started
seeing the advent of these models which
perhaps are like attributed to like re-
are
um
All right, very okay. Um
are basically the reasoning models. And
the reasoning models the key idea is
that like these models are not
instantaneously giving you an answer. Um
they can spend some time thinking about
what is going on, what the question
entails, going through the context,
maybe going through some tool calls,
understanding the context a little bit
more, and
allow got reasoning through them before
giving an answer.
And this really was a game changer
um
for many many different reasons.
Up until now, the primary axis of
compute which we were scaling up was the
during pre-training compute, but now we
could like actually increase the amount
of test time compute that these models
use. And perhaps like very importantly
so, when we increase the amount of test
and compute that these models use, the
model performance goes up predictably.
So, I have plotted a few benchmarks here
from the Gemini 2.5 report. Um the first
one is a benchmark called Amy 2025. This
is an American um
math competition with a final answer
problem. It's a high school level
problem which the LLMs were absolutely
terrible at um pre-2024.
But, as you can see that like the x-axis
is the amount of time a model can spend
thinking before an answer. And as this
time increases, the absolute performance
actually goes up by over 20 percentage
points.
And this is the same throughout all the
benchmarks. Like Code Bench is a
competitive coding programming
benchmark, and GPQA Diamond
is a science and knowledge benchmark.
And all of these metrics go up as the
model is allowed to think more and more
about the problems.
And
up until like 2024, like a lot of the
generational improvements were
conditioned on pre-training.
But, if you look at this report again,
Gemini 1.5 went to Gemini 2.5 Pro, and
I've highlighted some of the boxes, and
these are like dramatically large
improvements in performance. And these a
lot of these benchmarks are um
coding or science and knowledge or math.
And these benchmarks have gone up quite
dramatically, and a lot of these
improvements can be
attributed to inference time scaling
here.
Now, what is like inference time scaling
and test time compute? A lot of the
machine learning systems or at least
based on the neural networks were based
on like a fixed amount of forward
computation. You get an input, you do a
pass through some neural network, and
then you do your prediction or you
produce your output. And this is a fixed
amount of compute that a model will
spend
before giving you an output.
For a system which have like test time
built into them, they usually can
actually spend a lot more compute before
giving you an output. And the amount of
compute they spend,
there's some kind of a search procedure
either in the output space directly or
something of that form which allows it
to spend more compute than a single
forward pass
uh would have allowed the system to
spend.
And this ability to search and spend
more compute on input is typically what
is called like a test time compute
system.
The most prominent example of test time
compute perhaps is AlphaGo. Um AlphaGo
was a system built circa in the 2016 to
2018 kind of an era where um
these are the first neural networks to
beat humans at an exceptionally hard
game of Go. This was supposed to be a
benchmark where like humans were
supposed to excel and the AI systems
would never um
be at a human level. And one of the key
examples in this
key things in this research was
that when you have a model which is a
raw parametric model with a single fixed
forward pass, it reaches about an Elo
rating of 3,000. So it is the leftmost
bar in this figure.
And when you have the same model and you
add test time search on top of it, and
note the search is capped to maximum of
5 seconds,
when you add this uh search on top of
it,
the Elo jumps from 3,000 to 5,000. It's
the same model just with test time
search added on top.
This was quite an insane result because
a 100 Elo points is 200 like a 64% win
rate and
Elo gap is basically means that the
3,000 Elo player could never beat and
uh the 5,000 Elo player.
And
by the time you're around 3,500, you're
already absolutely superhuman. So, the
AlphaGo was the model which beat the
best Go player at the time.
So, this is one of the most prominent
use cases of test-time compute, but this
is very, very much hand-crafted to work
for
games and things which have access to a
simulator.
How do we enable LLMs to use test-time
compute?
Um
so, there's this idea which came up in
large language models, which is you
should can allow the model to have some
kind of chain of thought-based reasoning
before they answer. So,
let's say
um
the
one of the cool things about large
language models is you can typically
prompt them so that they start following
instructions much better. So, for
example, for standard prompting, let's
say the model that is told that it's
it's shown how to be solved a very, very
trivial math problem. Roger has five
tennis balls, he buys two more cans,
blah blah blah, how many balls does he
have now? The answer is 11.
Now, I'm asked a similar math problem,
and the model is like going to give you
an answer directly. And unfortunately,
when you force the models to give an
answer directly, they're typically not
very effective at this.
The idea in chain of thought prompting
was that instead of forcing the model to
answer correctly, the model is typically
encouraged to reason through the math or
reason through the steps before giving
an answer. So, Roger started with five
balls, two cans at three tennis balls
each is six tennis balls, 5 + 6 = 11.
The answer is 11.
So, it goes through these steps before
answering the question.
And now the next question when it sees
it, it is going to reason before it
reduces an answer. So, the cafeteria had
23 apples. They used 20 to make lunch.
So, that's 23 - 20 = 3. 3 + 6 = 9. So,
the answer is 9. And now the model is
correct.
So,
it kind of shows that when the language
model starts reasoning in natural
language, it tend to produce more
accurate and correct information as
responses.
This idea was exploited in this paper
called group relative policy
optimization from deep seek.
Um and it led to a really interesting
phenomena where if you warm start these
models to reason a little bit and you do
a lot of reinforcement learning um with
verifiable rewards, the reasoning sort
of emerges over the course of RL.
So, if you can look at this plot on the
right side, this is the RL training
curve and on the Y axis is the average
length per response. And this model is
trained on verifiable rewards. So,
situations where you typically know the
right answer to the problem or you can
verify what the right answer is. So,
think about math problems, think about
problems with code where you have unit
tests. So,
when you train the models using RL on
these verifiable domains, the response
length naturally starts to grow, which
tells that the model is now starting to
reason in natural language. And on the
left side, if you look at the blue
curve, the model starts with an accuracy
the training accuracy of like 25 15% and
it grows to 75 80% um
and this is all happening via RL, but
the important thing is that the
inference time computer is also being
used more and more through training and
through evaluation as well.
So,
yeah, one of the coolest things that
happened in this work was that it showed
that reasoning emerges almost naturally
over the course of RL as long as you
allow the model to use more influence
computer. And this was a very
fascinating phenomenon. It led to like
um a large set of improvements both in
open-source community, but also this was
being used in the frontier labs at the
time.
So, the question then like as I think
about it and many other people are
starting to think about it like can we
push test and compute more so for LLMs?
Currently like this kind of a natural
reasoning regime allows you to do an
influence time
increase the scale the influence time
computer via like chain of thought and
this isn't the only way to scale test of
time test time computer. So, there are
many other ways to scale test time
computer. For example, you can allow the
model to reason
multiple times in parallel
and you can allow the model to
take its previous answers and improve it
over with with multiple iterations. You
can allow the model access to tools such
as web search, code execution. You can
allow it sandbox environments. You can
allow like model to verify its own
answer and there's a lot of techniques
you can use to increase the amount of
test and computer the model uses and
improve its answer.
So, this kind of scaling of test time
computer led to many many different kind
of reasoning systems.
Gemini Deep Think, which I'll talk a
little bit more about, is an example of
such a system, but recently if you've
been using like any coding agentic
coding tools as well or if you have used
deep research agents, these are all
examples of what I think are scaling
test and compute, but more through
specific scaffold or harnesses around
like an LLM system. So, things like Deep
Think or ChatGPT Pro are more general
reasoning systems which uh can
answer a variety of queries, but use an
extended amount of inference time
compute. But, there's more specific
harnesses as well. So, Codex, Gemini
Deep Research, Cloud Code, Alethia is
another example like which are maybe
more targeted research agents, but still
use an
uh a large amount of test time compute.
Now, Gemini Deep Think is a system I
know a little bit more about, so I can
talk a little bit about it. Um it's an
amazing system where
you can put an arbitrary amount of test
time compute, and the model in principle
should keep improving its response.
Probably the most stark example of this
was the performance of the model on this
set of problems where it has to prove
very hard math problems like basically
IMO level.
And what we observed was quite
surprising is that if you look at the
plot here, the x-axis is the amount of
inference time being compute being used
on the log scale, and y-axis is the
accuracy of the proof. So, the proof is
either correct or incorrect as just by
an expert human.
And I think the difference between the
two curves is less important, but if we
focus on the blue curve, um
it's pretty clear that as we increase
the inference time compute, the model is
like about 40% accurate to about 90%
accurate. And this is
I want to clarify this is quite a lot of
compute. The model can work for hours
here before it produces an answer.
And it just keeps improving over time.
So, and a lot of machine learning
researchers love seeing like things
which can be scaled and predictably
improve performance. And this is one
such example.
Maybe perhaps like the interesting bit
about DeepMind is that it's not just
restricted to the reasoning problems,
not just maths, not just verifiable
things. The benefits actually do extend
to like non-verifiable domains as well.
So, in this example, um the model is
asked to produce um
an HTML file where like it has like a
whole voxel scene with cherry blossoms,
trees, and like pagodas.
And what I find fascinating is like 2.5
flash, which is like a small smaller
model, to 2.5 Pro, which is a larger
model, produces a fairly significant
improvement in how the UI looks. But by
scaling inference time computer that the
model used, we see an even larger
improvement on how much how many details
are added. So, if you look at the last
picture, um the cherry blossom trees
have a lot more detail going on in them.
The pagoda has so much more finer detail
available to it. And all of this is like
a function of increasing the test time
computer here.
So, the point being that like a general
extended inference computer system
produces like improvements across many,
many domains.
And overall like these systems are quite
remarkable, as I said. DeepMind Deep
Think was the first system which
achieved a gold medal standard at
International Mathematical Olympiad,
which was a goal or a milestone which
was not expected to be reached in 2025.
It's a very hard math problem
competition. And yeah,
um on the right was like a tweet, but
Codeforces is a competitive programming
platform where like
Gemini DeepMind, the latest version of
it, like got an Elo of approximately
3445.
And like to kind of ground this, there
was only like seven humans in the world
who are like better at
this than
um
than Gemini DeepMind.
And
if you follow along these days, like
it's not just math competitions, new
math problems, problems that researchers
are facing are being solved or at least
being helped substantially by these
models.
And these scaffoldings like got good now
or can like work for days to complete
large large engineering projects. So,
to kind of like put all of this in a
nutshell, over the last year, year and a
half, like
test-time scaling has been one of the
significant drivers of improvements of
AI systems. And like they're resulting
in systems which are now producing real
output in the world.
Okay, so hopefully like I was able to
like kind of tell you like all the
amazing progress that has happened with
test-time scaling. So, I'll briefly go
over like kind of what is going on right
now and what am I thinking about or some
of the like things that people at the
Frontier Labs are thinking about.
And yeah,
with test-time scaling, there's
still quite a lot of open questions
just related to fundamental
optimization.
I talked about how inference time
scaling results in very very predictable
gains, predictable improvements across
many domains. But the questions about
like how do we do this efficiently, how
do we use our tokens efficiently, how do
we use our tools efficiently is still
quite like an open question. And it's
something we can make a lot of progress
on.
One of the interesting things about
inference time scaling is that it's
and maybe this is like me not slightly
immediately obvious, but a lot of the
success in pre-training was driven by
increasing the depth of the model. And
inference time scaling is actually one
way to look at it is like it is
increasing the depth of competition as
well. Because you're allowing the model
to reason and produce more tokens before
answering the question, it's doing more
forward passes. So, in some like loose
sense, it is increasing the depth of
competition, too.
The question then becomes like what is
the most effective way to increase the
depth? Is it to increase the inference
time compute through tokens, or is there
other ways to increase depth of
computation as well?
And finally, like as short results from
agents which can do work for days or
hours or weeks,
we can like quite be sure that these
agents are going to start working longer
and longer and doing harder and harder
tasks. So, how can we make sure that
these agents can do the work
effectively? They're still making
progress. How can we optimize the AI
system so they're making progress even
after a couple of weeks? How do we
measure that they're making progress?
How do we make sure that they're making
progress safely? There's a lot we can do
about this, and these are all open
questions or things which are being
worked on right now.
And maybe to like, you know, it might
seem like a weird thought. Like, do we
really want agents to work for months?
And I think like we can be sure that
there's a lot of problems in this world
which we would like
uh these models to do.
Something very simple and maybe
Okay, I don't want to say simple, but
like solving the Riemann hypothesis.
It's very tangible that like this isn't
There's a million-dollar prize that is
associated with it. So, like and in
practice like the financial value of
solving this might be even higher. So,
like at the very least we can throw a
million dollars of compute at solving
something as a problem like this.
Now,
same with like
drug research, cancer treatment, or
anything which extends human life or
improves the quality of human life.
There's a lot of value and a lot of
compute we can throw behind such
problems. And, you know, companies
traditionally have made products by
scaling the number of engineers, but now
if you're building a new revolutionary
product, like, how much inference
compute would you be willing to pay for
to like build this like really cool
product? I imagine a lot.
But, I think it's also like useful for
me to talk about that
we have been scaling like inference
compute, we are scaling how much work
agents can do, and
this is not going to solve every single
problem
um that we face, and it will make a
tremendous amount of progress, it will
drive a
large amount of innovation, but as
an AI researcher, I think there's some
still things missing which I believe
could be like interesting to work on.
So, one of the key things I think is
knowledge discovery. Knowledge discovery
The models can solve well-defined
problems extremely well by working like
a lot of time, a lot of inference
compute. But, it's often hard for the
models to figure out like what problems
matter and what kind of impact they will
have on the world. Um recently, like,
that was proposed something called the
Einstein test, which I think is an
interesting thing where the model is
asked to rediscover the general theory
of relativity training on data only up
to like early 20th century, which is an
interesting test about can the model
discovering something like so abstract
and something so revolutionary?
Um so, knowledge discovery is still
pretty hard, and one other thing that I
think is interesting and cool to work on
is like how can the agents improve with
experience? Humans when they work jobs
or go through school or go through
research, they typically become better
researchers, better engineers, better at
what they're doing. But, agentic work
it's
even though it uses a lot of infant
computer and typically gets better, it
is it can still be expensive. If you're
doing a thing repeatedly, like you don't
want to go through the same loop over
and over again. And maybe another way to
see this is like some tool calls or some
things can be extremely expensive and
reusing them over and over is not the
best or the most efficient way to use
computer.
So,
we would like AI systems that can
improve with experience, that form the
right intuitions about the problems,
that can shortcut rather than reason
from first principle every single time
they encounter the same problem.
And this is something which would be
like great to build AI systems for.
And yeah, I think that's all I have to
say for today. Hope like hopefully like
you see a little bit of into peek into
the frontier labs and like how we're
thinking about test time scaling.
>> [applause]
>> Hi. Thank you for the nice talk.
Uh most of these work on test time
scaling is done on token space.
What do you think uh the progress might
be going forward in working on latent
spaces for the this test time scaling?
You think this has some future?
Thank you. Yeah, that's a great
question. So, this is maybe perhaps like
I was also hinting to it is
um
token space is has a lot of benefits. Uh
a lot of the language models are trained
to predict tokens and think in natural
language. So, scaling inference compute
by scaling
uh into the token space which is
actually very natural for the language
models. This is why like reasoning
emerges in things like GRPL.
But,
it's arguably not the most efficient
space to think in.
The continuous space offers so much more
space to represent thoughts, things
which are maybe even more abstract. And
you know, our language models like the
internal representations of them are in
like continuous spaces. So,
we can consider scaling them up. It's
much harder to get a system of that form
working, but people are working on it,
yes.
Yeah.
Hi, thanks for the great talk.
Um I wanted to ask so one of the
benefits of
or like side effects I guess of test
time compute is a lot more data that
gets generated from these conversations.
And of course, as you kind of pointed
out in your last point, um
of course with experience you expect
these models to get better, hopefully.
Um
And so I'm wondering like have you seen
any evidence of that already? And do you
think
um future models would just create
massive amount of shortcuts and not have
to work for hours, but instead you know,
get trained on a lot of these um
external
or like new data that got generated.
Um because I think three points that you
mentioned uh related to like how to
scale it is like paralyzed COT, right?
Which I think you can definitely get
shortcuts on. Or train like through
training. Iterative self-refinement I
also think you can you can improve
further. And so the last thing that
remains is like web search. So,
I wonder if you've seen any evidence of
that.
Yeah, that's a good question. So, um
I think like there's already signs of
like memories being used. Um people can
create memories. Or if you have like
looked at skills, I think skill is a
great example of like how like a lot of
the agenda coding systems like
humans can add skills or coding systems
can remember remember things that
they've done before
and that allows the models to like
shortcut some of the things rather than
rediscovering them.
Overall I think like there's some
argument to be made that these are
improving with experience but it's still
pretty manual overall. I think there is
a lot of headroom or a lot of
ways we can do that but I think yeah
this is very early on. I would say
there's a lot of things we can do even
right now.
Hey thanks for the for the talk.
For for those of us that haven't spent
time ourselves researching
um
the methods in which we've
had um
learned reasoning through verifiable
problems. Can you tell us a little bit
about the challenges associated with
moving from simple examples of
verifiable problems so simple math
problems, simple coding problems to
scaling that to domains where today
we're seeing
models capable of working through very
complex proofs and and what needed to
happen to to really scale it up to
that point?
Yeah.
There's a few set of problems. I think
like first of all like
it's like
maybe not well appreciated but the
building the infrastructure is actually
quite incredibly hard for RL scaling.
The models need to train very very
stably. The models
need to like not diverge in multiple
different ways.
The divergence can come through this is
talked about in the open community as
well so like um,
training mismatch can often like
exaggerate over the course of our
training which can cause like a fairly
bad divergence in performance.
Um,
and there's a lot of like funny quirky
things that can come up like,
um,
then people spend a lot of time
optimizing something like the compute
efficiency which allows the model to
reach a certain amount of performance.
So that, um, in like a certain number of
tokens over the course of training.
Um, the other thing which I think is
important and which is partly solved by
the use of verifiable problems, but
is that these things are extremely data
limited. So, verifiable problems are
nice but
um,
you run out of them fairly quickly. So,
you start with easy problems, but as you
train and especially if these are like
very strong pre-trained models, you run
out of them very quickly because very
easy problems stop carrying any
significant signal for the learning for
these models. So, when you start
reaching like the problem like proofs or
something of those form,
um, math proofs are actually like not
that easy to verify.
So,
um,
depending on how you do it, these things
can still get hacked and you have to
work around these issues as well.
So, harder domains are harder to verify,
there's fewer of them, so you have to be
more efficient on learning of them.
And then you have to also come up with
like good methods that like allow you to
scale infants compute in the ways we
have talked about.
Hey, so you talked about scaling test
time compute to maybe even months of
work, but from our own experience, like
models just make bad decisions at some
point after days and they never look
back. So, is this because of like a
jagged front line that models are good
in one way but bad in other ways? Or how
can like how can we scale it up even
more to month of work?
Yeah, that's a good question. So, um
I think um
Yeah, I think
the models still make mistakes. The
models will still get stuck in the wrong
directions that
um
Like I do so as well. Like sometimes I
get stuck wrong on the wrong idea, and
then I I do not recover from it till
somebody pulls me out of it. So, this is
part of the problem we want to solve.
So, like when when I talk about agents
working for months, you want to you
don't want to like come back to it and
it just hasn't solved or made progress
on the problem. If it is stuck, like
asking
somebody else or other agents or other
humans to like help it better understand
the problem.
So,
yeah, there's still work to be done on
this aspect. Um
Part of it might be the jaggedness.
These are really good at solving things.
Part of it is like handling under
specification. Often like the problems
are not well specified and they
misunderstand the problem.
And then get stuck. So, there's a few
things which need to improve for these
models to be able to work effectively
for on the order of months.
Cool.
Um I think that's it for from our side.
Let's uh thank again Arkit for fantastic
talk.
>> [applause]
>> Yeah. It was great being here. Thank you
for inviting me. Yeah, thank you so much
for taking the time. We'll see you soon,
Arkit.
All right. Bye. Bye.